i feel like she and max are still
together but i think allison's from
salem and he wants to always be in
california so i think they did some sort
of compromise and so maybe she's in
salem when the witches come back we
shall be back in the lives the children
shall be mine
hello
mom
hey
honey oh my little girl
oh my gosh vanessa the blazing world was
such a
mind-melting film how are you describing
this crazy project to your family and
friends i i agree it is a fantastic
world to enter into and what's so great
about it is that it is fantastical it is
otherworldly literally but
what is wonderful about it and what
people can really grasp is that it's
grounded in
some sort of reality where it's
um really the story of a young woman
who's really dealt with a lot of traumas
and is revisiting them in a way that's
healthy
in some ways
and not ignoring them anymore um and
you know she's in a desperate situation
to begin with by way of revisiting parts
of her past she's able to
move into the future and her family is
as well
it just so happens that halloween is
based on the ancient feast called all
hallows eve
it's the one night of the year where the
spirits of the dead can return to earth
well set alison
gotta talk to you about hocus pocus it
wouldn't be halloween without people
absolutely freaking out about this movie
what do you remember the most about
filming that more than 25 years ago well
i grew up watching disney movies
so you know
the fact that i got to be in a disney
movie at 16 years old was like my dream
come true
and the fact that it was directed by
kenny ortega and bette midler and
snatched parker and kathy jimmy and then
my friends like literally were thor
birch and armory cats like it was just
it basically was everything i could have
dreamed of to be in a movie like that
again it was like just the cat being
like one of the first like you know cgi
cats and all these breakthrough kind of
things and like you know the witches on
the harnesses and running after us and
just this like sensory overload for me
as a child you know and then every day
just having fun and running from witches
like what what more could i have asked
for as a teen actor exactly oh you mean
the sanderson sisters
i know all about them my mom used to run
the museum there's a museum about it
yeah but they shut it down because
a lot of spooky things happen there you
know fans are of course freaking out
because disney just announced that they
will be doing a hocus pocus sequel the
sanderson sisters are coming back what
are the chances that we can get the
coolest girl in salem allison to be in
this movie vanessa what can you tell me
i don't i haven't heard anything i know
it's so disappointing but i know i would
love to do the sequel it'd be so much
fun
um
i think there's just a different
storyline i think it's with younger
people but why why can't we all come
back in some some way i want to see what
allison is up to today what do you think
she's up to do you think she and max
were endgames i feel like she and max
are still together but i think you know
alice alison is from salem and he wants
to always be in california so
i think they did some sort of compromise
and so maybe she's in salem when the
witches come back you know visiting her
mom or something i think that it's their
kids who should then light the black
flame candle again right like yes like
like back to the future where the kids
are messing everything up in the sequel
yeah oh come on it's just a bunch of
hocus pocus
max i'm not kidding this time it's time
to go
max no
[Music]
this film has only grown in popularity
which is insane since it came out 28
years ago
and i feel like the fans now know like
every little fact about it but do you
have a behind-the-scenes fun factor
memory that you think fans would be
surprised to know
uh some fun fact and memory that i
personally enjoyed which was the cats
what was so cool about these cats was
like there was literally a wall of cats
that could all do one thing and they
trained them to do one thing so if they
jumped on your shoulder that was the one
thing they could do or if they you know
slept on you and you're holding them
that was the best cat for that job and
the cat who likes slammed the book
clothes when we're trying to figure out
a spell um
running from the sisters i know there's
so much more but i think that's the one
fun fact because not many people know
that there was not just one cat but
there's like literally 25. cat's got my
tongue
oh wait no there is one other fact i'm
so sorry okay so the ballroom the ball
dress the ball gown yeah in the
beginning was supposed to be worn the
entire movie
and
all of us the the i have to like commend
the costume designer she's like you
really want her running through the
graveyards and this is just not gonna
work it's so much material and so we all
revisited it and i think kenny was like
probably voting for me to have go change
i'll be i'm gonna go upstairs and go
change versus just exiting in that crazy
ball gown
okay let me get changed and never miss
me
which is another fun fact is that
michelle pfeiffer wore that in dangerous
liaisons that same ballgame so what i
know so i got to where michelle
pfeiffer's i mean who i idolize um
wore it after her so i feel
maybe she rubbed off on me somehow
that's amazing i think you just like
blew all the hocus pocus fans mine so
i'm so glad that you wore the cream
sweater because it's iconic it is isn't
it so iconic and i'm so bummed about the
red um hooded cape i was like i should
have just demanded to keep that thing
but
i didn't i didn't keep any of the
clothes why didn't i do that anyway
i do have the memories in my heart i
couldn't wear anything like that because
i don't have any what do you call max
yabbo's
i love that how many people try to send
you salt
actually nobody has sent me salt that's
very very
[Music]
what a funny little white witch
i love it and we all do as well uh
bringing it back one more question about
the blazing world what would you say was
the most challenging aspect of bringing
your character alice winter to life for
this film i read it and i really
resonated with her childlike aspect you
know she's definitely it just has
dissociative disorder so she's in her
own world and i felt like it was more
like her playing as a child and so
therefore it wasn't as scary for me um
so i was able to come out of it and you
know enjoy
going in that to that dark direction she
really is a piece of work alice you know
she's literally not in this planet you
know
just a little bit just a little bit yeah
she is imprisoned between life
and death
let me bring her back she is held
by three demons to open the door
find this way
and take their keys and i wonder they're
not going to be as nice to you as i am
[Music]
you